[MUSIC] The
team sitting on the throne is free 2nd round,
at least until the 3rd round. As the game progresses, more teams will participate.  It would be
easier to sit on the throne at this stage rather
than fighting with other teams while aiming for the crown.
Even so, I don't think we can take the crown from that girl I
can do it Ahhh I'll leave the
method to you
Anyway, you training even if you're wearing a jersey I'm going to
keep you away from the throne I'm
crumbling
[music]
me
Harako Yokarou
[Music] It's an
Abeno store, gay guy, it's a secret meeting
If the guy who can control half of the body's water wasn't hiding
I can aim for the throne from anywhere
Guidance ah,
delay
[music] [
applause] I
said you can see it, but
then I'll be yours from here
[music] That's
right  Taka